the Americans sent their circus freaks  to test us we will send them back in  bags nice right now I'm going to  surrender you delete everything if we  give the Avengers the weapons they may  not look too fine to what we've been the  twinners they are not ready to take her  no no I mean  [Music]  we have an enhancing the feel somebody  want to deal with that bunker jabber  smite closing in you see a power source  for that shield doesn't populate above  the bolt our great I want to poke it  something  drawbridge is down people the annonced  piece of luck all the new players we  face I've never seen this in fact I  still haven't pretty bad guys we're  gonna need evac I can get baggage the  jet soon will go on the better you in  stock secure the scepter copy that good  lining up well they're excited and for  gosh sake watch your language that's not  going away anytime soon  guys stop we got to talk this through  it's good talk  you